im anschluss kostentransparenz unser
thema heute unser bestimmendes thema
heute dieses heutigen montages die
wahlnachlese zu berlin
ich begrüße es dass ge spitzenkandidat
zum ab zur abgeordnetenhauswahl in
berlin als bundesvorstandsmitglied der
afg ich begrüße frauke petry die
bundesvorsitzende der afg und auch heute
ebenfalls bundesvorsitzende der afb
die drei sind zu uns bekommen um eben
auch wahlnachlese zu betreiben erklärt
wie bei ihnen geht es los
ja danke schön ja guten morgen oder
guten tag meine damen und herren
mit 14 ist die afd ins abgeordnetenhaus
in berlin eingezogen
für uns ist das ein sensationelles
ergebnis kommt noch dazu dass wir fünf
direktmandate im osten berlins gewonnen
haben
wir werden wahrscheinlich sieben
stadträte in berlin stellen und wir
gehen davon aus dass die parteien auch
uns die gelegenheit geben in den
bezirksverordnetenversammlungen
entsprechend politik mitzugestalten
das ist eine neue qualität die afg wird
auch regierungsverantwortung übernehmen
in den bezirken und da hoffen wir
natürlich auf die demokraten die wir
auch hier sind dass sie uns entsprechend
mit einbeziehen
unser erfolg von gestern zeigt
eigentlich auch die aktie ist jetzt auch
in den großstädten angekommen und ich
denke berlin eine stadt die sich oder wo
sich viele berliner auch als links
bezeichnen wenn die so ein erfolg hat
dann denke ich hat es auch eine große
strahlkraft auf deutschland wir haben im
osten berlins haben wir 17 prozent
geholt im westen berlins 12 prozent und
das zeigt auch dass die afg nicht nur
ein ostdeutsches phänomen ist wie es oft
gesagt wird ich denke wir sind
mittlerweile überall in deutschland
angekommen
die wahlanalyse zeigt etwas ganz
besonderes aus meiner sicht dass die afg
im prinzip das größte demokratischen
projekt der letzten jahrzehnte ist
wir haben es wieder einmal geschafft
viele nichtwähler elf prozent nicht
wähler an die urne zu bringen
wir haben die wahlbeteiligung deutlich
erhöht und das ist einzig und allein der
afg zu verdanken
wir sagen nicht dass alle die fdp müssen
nein wir sagen natürlich in die wälder
hin und wählen die parteien die sie für
richtig halten
aber wir schaffen es dass der wähler
wieder an die urne geht und ich denke
das ist etwas ganz besonderes und
darüber freue ich mich ganz besonders
die afg hat auch folgendes geschafft
hier in berlin wir haben zum ersten mal
plakate auch gemacht und habe die nicht
wähler angesprochen und haben die
nichtwähler gezielt angesprochen dass
sie zur wahl gehen sollen
das war uns ein großes anliegen denn ich
denke damit leisten wir eine ganze menge
für die demokratie
ja wenn ich wenn ich mir die
zusammensetzung unserer wähler anschaue
dann haben wir es wieder mal geschafft
bei den arbeitern eine ganze menge von
arbeitern zu gewinnen während 18 prozent
die spd als gewählt haben 16 prozent die
linken ist unser anteil in dieser
bevölkerungsgruppe bei 27 prozent der
stimmen
und auch wenn uns die gewerkschaften
immer alle möglichen knüppel zwischen
die beine werfen denke ich doch dass das
ein tolles ergebnis
offensichtlich sprechen wir die straße
wie die sprache des bürgers auf der
straße und auch die sprache der arbeiter
wie geht es nun weiter mit der afd
lassen sie mich erst einmal auf unseren
ehrgeizigen terminkalender verweisen
wir werden bereits morgen mit den
abgeordneten den 25 abgeordneten
zusammen kommen und werden die
konstituierende sitzung der fraktion
durchführen und wir hoffen dass wir in
dieser woche auch schon die wahlen
durchgeführt haben eine satzung
beschlossen haben und die weichen für
die zukunft stellen können
ich freue mich sehr darauf mit meinen
neuen fraktionskollegen
zusammenzuarbeiten und ich weiß dass wir
ein ausgezeichnetes team haben wir haben
aber auch eine politische agenda in
berlin
wir sind angetreten um auf den
oppositionsbänken
im abgeordnetenhaus den regierenden
scharf auf die finger zu schauen
wir sind angetreten damit endlich die
interessen aller bürger eine stimme im
parlament haben im abgeordnetenhaus wie
in den bezirksverordnetenversammlungen
aber wir sind natürlich auch angetreten
um ganz konkrete fortschritte hier in
berlin zu erzählen und wenn ich ja die
alte regierung höhere und mir gestern
abend auch in den talkrunden angehört
habe was hier für ja ich sag mal
berichte verbreitet werden wie tolles in
berlin ist dann kann ich ihnen sagen da
wird permanent den bürgern sand in die
augen gestreut
denn berlin geht es nicht so toll wie
immer wieder gesagt wird
es gibt erhebliche probleme in berlin
das wissen wir
wir haben ein problem der inneren
sicherheit wir haben ein bildungsproblem
berlin hat zum zweiten mal auf dem
letzten platz im bildungsmonitor
abgeschnitten und das es eigentlich
verheerend für eine stadt berlin hat ein
wohnungsproblem berlin hat ein
verkehrsproblem und ich könnte immer so
weitermachen und die fünf jahre cdu spd
regierung haben wenig daran geändert und
ich habe die ganz ganz große befürchtung
dass rot rot grün so weitermachen wird
oder die ganze situation in berlin noch
verschlimmern wird aber da werden wir
vor seien außen vor sein und wir werden
versuchen das zu verhindern
wir werden hier in berlin keine
fundamental opposition sein sondern wir
werden versuchen uns konstruktiv
einzubringen und für mich und für unsere
fraktion wird es so sein
jeder der das wohl berlins im auge hat
die zukunft berlins in ob im auge hat
und das wohl der bürger der kann mit uns
rechnen
wer aber versucht ein weiter so hier in
berlin zu machen
der wirt probleme mit uns bekommen und
zwar in der opposition
wir werden den finger in die wunde legen
wir werden die probleme ansprechen und
wir werden nichts unter den teppich
kehren lassen
das ist unser credo wir strecken
allerdings und das will ich auch
deutlich sagen die hand zur
zusammenarbeit aus und ich hoffe dass
auch die anderen demokraten das
verstehen wir werden nichts und
niemanden aus ideologischen gründen
vorurteilen ablehnen wenn er
in der sache recht und gute argumente
hat
wir werden nichts wir erwarten dies in
einer demokratie und umgekehrt genauso
von den anderen
wir wollen als opposition im
abgeordnetenhaus klar wo nötig auch hart
in der sache seien aber zugleich auch
fair im umgang mit den anderen
fraktionen
ich denke das ist es was die bürger von
uns verlangen und das ist unser auftrag
den wir von den bürgern gekriegt haben
und dafür stehen wir und dafür können
sie uns auch beim wort nehmen herzlichen
dank vielen dank bis hierher ich möchte
darauf aufmerksam machen dass wir zeit
haben bis zu 13 uhr 10 die nächste
veranstaltung steht an den hausbau petri
bitte guten tag meine damen und herren
nach dem herbst erst jetzt gerade eine
einordnung für berlin vorgenommen hat
werde ich es für die bundes partei
fortsetzen
es ist schon gesagt wurden dies ist das
zehnte landesparlament in das die
alternative für deutschland seit dem 31
august 2014 das war der tag der
sächsischen landtagswahl eingezogen ist
man kann es auch andersherum sehen als
countdown bis zur bundestagswahl
wir sind noch drei landtagswahlen von
der bundestagswahl entfernt und sind
überzeugt davon dass das was die
berliner so eindrucksvoll in einem für
die afc im wahlkampf sehr schwierigen
umfeld geleistet haben
als nächstes vor allen dingen sichtbar
in nordrhein westfalen fortgesetzt
werden wird und kurz davor in den etwas
kleineren bundesländern saarland und in
schleswig holstein
fakt ist doch obwohl die spd sich als
wahlsieger feiert haben sie das
schlechteste ergebnis ihrer geschichte
in berlin eingefahren
und wenn man so gern nach landtagswahlen
die prozentzahlen bemüht die gegen und
nicht auf die gewählt haben dann wollen
wir diese tradition gern aufnehmen und
stellen fest dass mehr als 78 prozent
der berliner wähler nicht die spd
gewählt haben
die cdu ein historisch schlechtes
ergebnis eingefahren hat und die große
koalition nicht mehr groß ist sondern
weiter schrumpft und wir nun auch in
berlin zu einer dreier-koalition kommen
werden bei der zu befürchten ist das
sagte georg gerade schon
dass gerade der finanz aspekt der
landesführung weiter schaden nehmen wird
schon jetzt ist berlin als
bundeshauptstadt massiv von bundes- und
zuschüssen aus dem länderfinanzausgleich
abhängig das wird sich wohl auch unter
möglicherweise rot rot grün nicht ändern
sogar verschlimmern und hier wird die
afd rego rose haushaltskontrolle
betreiben und auf missstände hinweisen
apropos missstände wenn man der
konkurrenz glaubt dann ist ja das was
der alternative für deutschland ganz
gern als schlächter populismus
vorgeworfen wird in wirklichkeit nur
eine benennung der probleme so sagt es
heute morgen herr oppermann von der spd
in einem interview auf die frage ob auch
nicht die spd ängste geschürt haben
vielleicht können wir in zukunft einmal
dazu kommen dass es völlig normal in der
politik ist das problem benannt werden
und dass bürger emotional darauf
reagieren und deswegen stellen wir fest
dass die alternative für deutschland
offenbar auch in berlin eines geschafft
hat nämlich zu zeigen dass es
alternative politikansätze gibt und dass
wir diejenigen sind die lösungen
kreieren und nicht wie die union
neuerdings lösungen kopieren wofür sie
dann trotzdem nicht gewählt werden
wir haben außerdem das lässt sich
statistisch ganz klar nachweisen für
eine um elf prozent höhere
wahlbeteiligung gesorgt
inzwischen gibt es offensichtlich auch
politiker die mehr wahlbeteiligung die
der asd primär nützt dann vielleicht gar
nicht für einen der sich großen
demokratie zu gewinnen halten
eine derartige interpretation können sie
sich vorstellen lehnen wir
selbstverständlich ab je mehr bürger an
der wahl ohne ihre meinung äußern und
besser noch wenn wir zukünftig mehr zu
sagen haben in form direkter demokratie
tatsächlich auch mitentscheiden können
nur dies der demokratie in diesem land
nutzen und deswegen werden wir uns auf
bundesebene weiterhin dafür einsetzen
nur noch ein kurzes wort zu denjenigen
die uns gewählt haben da ist ja schon zu
lesen gewesen das sei der rand von
berlin gewesen vor allen dingen
arbeiter oder auch angehöriger mittlerer
und unterer einkommensschichten
ich verweise darauf dass die partei die
sich hier als weise gefeiert
einmal angeblich die partei der kleinen
leute gewesen ist wenn ein franz
müntefering sich hinstellt und sagt mit
600 euro im monat sei man nicht arm
sieht man wie ernst die partei ihre
ehemaligen villa nimmt und dass diese
weder dann unter anderem aufzuraffen
überlaufen
das ist konsequent demokratisches
verhalten dass wir weiterhin vor allen
dingen im ruhrgebiet am 14
unterstützen werden dann setze ich den
reigen fort
und sie müssen nicht befürchten dass ich
lange rede nach der devise ist es alles
gesagt aber noch nicht von jedem bis das
meiste gesagt ein paar ergänzende ganz
wenige ergänzende überlegungen
einbringen
ich bin gestern gefragt worden den
interviews ist das jetzt nicht
eigentlich ein schlechtes ergebnis im
vergleich zu mecklenburg vorpommern und
ich will dass wir das hier noch mal zum
besten geben das ist natürlich überhaupt
nicht vergleichbar den mecklenburg
vorpommern ist ein flächenland ganz
ländlich strukturierten wir müssen das
wahlergebnis dass wir hier in berlin
haben vergleichen mit den
wahlergebnissen die wir den anderen
beiden stadtstaaten hatten und
demzufolge haben wir deutlich mehr als
das doppelte
im wahlergebnis am ende des wahlabends
erzielt als das in hamburg oder in
bremen der fall war
und das ist ein grandioser erfolg der
berliner afd jetzt anhand großer erfolg
von der ski der im wahlkampf eine tolle
rolle gespielt hat und von all den
vielen die ihr unter sehr schwierigen
bedingungen wahlkampf betrieben haben
das ist ein schweres milieu für die afg
wir sind eine konservative partei das
wissen sie
und die tun sich traditionell im
großstädtischen milieus schwerer als
etwa im ländlichen raum
und wenn wir dann aus dem aus dem stand
heraus hier in berlin 14 2 prozent
erzielen dann ist das ein grandioser
erfolg
lasst mich vielleicht eine kleine
randbemerkung machen zu hertha als
generalsekretär der cdu der hat im
hinblick auf das berliner wahlergebnis
harmoniert der fisch stinkt bekanntlich
vom kopf so hat das gestern nur gesagt
dann kann ich ihm ausnahmsweise nur
beipflichten in der tat
und darum erlebt die cdu in berlin hätte
dabei natürlich auch das miserable
wahlergebnis der spd ab mit recht aber
er übersieht dabei völlig dass die cdu
in berlin auch ihr fünftes wahl desaster
in folge erlebt währenddessen feiert die
spd einen weiteren vermeintlichen sieg
jedoch tatsächlich keiner ist wenn sie
sich mal überlegen dass diese partei
21,6 prozent erzielt hat bei dieser wahl
ein historisches tief
sie vergleichen das mal mit dem was als
bestes ergebnis der spd jemals erzielt
wohl deshalb willy brandt anfang der
60er jahre mit 62 prozent ist das gerade
noch ein drittel der stimmen die diese
partei auf sich vereinen kann
und das hat gründe die wurden auch schon
angesprochen das ist ein miserables
sozialpolitik die sind für jedermann
sehen in auges offenkundig gerade hier
in berlin exemplarisch genannt die
sozialpolitik und die absolut miserables
bildungs lage in der stadt
und dann kommen solche ergebnisse heben
dabei heraus wir die afg haben andere
vorstellungen wie man landespolitik hier
in berlin machen sollte wie auch im bund
und es ist nicht zu übersehen dass immer
mehr bürger sich davon überzeugen lassen
immer mehr menschen erkennen dass wir
eine echte alternative nicht nur für
berlin sondern für deutschland sind das
ist gut so und was mich besonders freut
es wird schon zwei mal gesagt darum dass
nur ganz kurz zum schluss dass mit
dieser wahlbeteiligung ist natürlich
eine irre geschichte
das ist mehr das wird immer so gerne als
als nette randnotiz genommen aber wissen
sie das ist mehr als eine nette
begleiterscheinung wenn wir elf prozent
mehr menschen an die wahlurne bringe als
vorher und das maßgeblich mit unserem
antreten zur wahl zu tun hat dann ist
das wirklich ein grandioser sieg für die
demokratie dem selbst unsere gegner
respekt zollen müssen das so weiter
meiner seite
vielen dank vielen dank für die
statements wir sind bei fragen und weil
eben nicht alle alle kennen bitte ich
auch an dieser stelle wieder um eine
kurze vorstellung auch wenn mir der 100
name einfällt herr jung gerade im blick
auf bisherige erfahrungen landtag würde
ich gerne wissen wie viele von den jetzt
25 abgeordneten abgeordnetenhaus
antisemiten sind das die frage meinen
sie nicht ernst ich verstehe die
jungmusik ganz ehrlich sagen frank samer
ich denke ich denke dass alle die jetzt
im abgeordnetenhaus bringen sind dort
demokraten sind auf dem boden der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
stehen und von daher verbietet sich
diese frage
ich habe noch eine frage zu einem ihrer
direktkandidaten herrn erst mayer hat in
lichtenberg das direktmandat gewonnen
der wahlberliner chef der german defence
league die nach eigener auf der nach
eigener aussage auch eine miliz aufbauen
wollte die german defence league wird
als rechtsextrem eingestuft mich würde
interessieren
pastörs welche rolle ernst mayer in ihre
fraktion spielen soll und frau petra
erneuten ging erstmal läuft ein
parteiordnungsverfahren wie es da das
stammt also ich denke das kann ich am
besten beantworten erstes mal heißt der
herrnsheimer es hat ein direktmandat in
berlin
und er war 2012 hat er war er in der
german defence league oder in dieser
organisation aktiv das war also lange
bevor die afg gegründet worden ist
2013 wurde diese organisation durch den
verfassungsschutz in bremen über
überwacht
aber da war der betroffene schon längst
ausgetreten und hat eigentlich nicht
mehr dafür gearbeitet
das heißt also wir nehmen die sache sehr
ernst sie haben vollkommen recht
wir haben die sache auch untersucht und
wir sind noch dabei zu untersuchen und
sie können sicher sein dass wir das so
untersuchen werden dass wir auch eine
vernünftige gute lösung finden werden
die frage nach dem
parteiausschlussverfahren also darüber
geben wir hier erst mal keine auskunft
und wenn sie so interessiert daran sind
und uns gerne dabei helfen unsere
mitglieder oder auch abgeordneten zu
prüfen dann empfehle ich ihnen das
vielleicht bei cdu und spd und anderen
parteien in bezug auf ehemalige
npd-mitglieder genauso zu machen
herr kollege bitte
andreas niesmann redaktions netzwerk
deutschland herr platz der sg selm
selber neben kurz darauf hingewiesen die
direktmandate die im ostteil der stadt
gewonnen worden sind das sind ja
teilweise hochburgen der linkspartei wo
ja viel vier wahlen in folge gewonnen
wurde haben sie die linke dort als
protestpartei nummer eins abgelöst und
eine zweite frage welche rolle spielten
russlanddeutsche dabei aus ihrer sicht
ja ich von mir erst mal zur zweiten
frage natürlich haben wir uns auch um
die russlanddeutschen bemüht so wie das
die cdu beispielsweise auch gemacht hat
nur waren wir diesmal wahrscheinlich
erfolgreich aber mir liegen die zahlen
noch nicht ganz vor
wir haben ich sag mal viel
übereinstimmung auch mit den
einstellungen bei den russlanddeutschen
bei den russlanddeutschen spielen
beispielsweise die die themen familie
innere sicherheit bildung spielen eine
große rolle
und da hat offensichtlich die afd das
beste programm vorgelegt sodass wir auch
gewählt worden sind
bei den ja ich sag mal im osten und bei
den linken ich denke natürlich war auch
eine gewisse anteil protest war dabei
das ist ganz klar aber ich glaube eher
dass es auch zum teil einer abstimmung
über die flüchtlings und
migrationspolitik der bundesregierung
war auf der anderen seite haben wir
natürlich auch eine ganze menge vom
berliner themen angesprochen die die
berliner berühren und da habe ich vorhin
schon mal kurz gesagt das ist die innere
sicherheit das ist die bildungspolitik
dass die verkehrspolitik
das ist natürlich auch das flüchtlings
chaos das hier in berlin immer noch
nicht geregelt ist und da hat die fdp
offensichtlich die richtigen themen
angesprochen und deshalb sind wir auch
gewählt worden
ich habe zwei fragen einen kasten
entschuldigung florian kain bild zeitung
herr pastörs könnt ihr euch zu sichern
dass sie die ganze legislatur im
abgeordnetenhaus bleiben oder
planen sie auch schon ihren wechsel in
den bundestag sowie frau petra und die
zweite frage an frau petri ich habe sie
gestern bei der wahlparty vermisst
hatten sie da keine einladung oder warum
man sich da vielleicht vielleicht kann
ich das zunächst beantworten natürlich
war die frau petra eingeladen
das ist doch selbstverständlich und es
gab andere gründe aber die kann sie
vielleicht darstellen das will ich hier
nicht tun
auf der anderen seite das habe ich immer
wieder gesagt ich bin jetzt hier ins
berliner abgeordnetenhaus gewählt und
werde mich natürlich auch um den
fraktionsvorsitz bemühen und zunächst
ist meine aufgabe hier in berlin ich
werde dort meine aufgabe erfüllen wo die
mitglieder mich sehen wollen
wenn das in berlin es werde ich in
berlin bleiben wenn die mitglieder sagen
ich soll in die bunten in den bundestag
gehen werde ich mich natürlich auch zur
verfügung stellt mir geht's darum dort
meine arbeit zu leisten wo ich das am
besten kann und wo mich die mitglieder
sehen
danke wenn man vier kinder hat muss man
sich ab und zu um sie kümmern
deswegen war ich gestern bei meiner
familie weil mein sohn ich krank war
er kochte ja hannes koch die
korrespondenten herr pastörs gg fdp will
einen stufentarif in der einkommensteuer
einführen
laut deutschem institut für
wirtschaftsforschung würde das
bundesweite ein finanzloch von 50
milliarden euro
produzieren wollen sie die
mehrwertsteuer erhöhen um dieses loch zu
spielen also ich würde das thema gerne
dem erneuten wiedergeben der kann ihn
bestimmt was dazu sagen aber das papier
stammt auch von der afg berlin
nein das sind bundes thema und deshalb
will ich gerne annehme morgen übergeben
also das ist ich kann er weiter helfen
das ist ein thema das im
bundesfachausschuss finanzen arbeit
soziales besprochen wird den ich relativ
lange geleitet habe seit einiger zeit
nicht mehr weiß meine zeit nicht erlaubt
und wir sind in der tat über
verschiedene stufen tarife nach diese
berechnungen was dabei herauskommt die
sind hochspekulativ und je nachdem wie
man einen stufentarif ausgestaltet kann
es ein paar milliarden am anfang kosten
oder auch nicht was sie aber immer sehen
müssen ist dass das steueraufkommen sich
an multiplikatoren setzt aus tarif und
bemessungsgrundlage und gehen sie
getrost davon aus dass wenn wir mit
einem stufentarif machen der arbeit an
reihte bietet in sent to work dann wird
die bemessungsgrundlage steigen und dann
werden wir dieses problem nicht haben
abgesehen davon darf ich auch die
geradezu famose vermute finanzlage des
bundes hinweisen so dass wir hier also
nicht eine deckungslücke haben die man
etwa über die mehrwertsteuer schließen
müsse die frage stellt sich nicht
und das müsste man dann eben auch sehen
die man den tarif genau ausgestaltet wir
haben verschiedene modelle mit denen wir
arbeiten
die zahl vom diw ist vergleichsweise
spekulativ mit einigen dutzend
milliarden steuerausfälle müssten sie
rechnen daher nochmal die frage welche
steuern wollen sie erhöhen um dieses
loch zu schließen
ich habe die frage im prinzip
beantworten wir wollen keine steuern
erhöhen im gegenteil wir wollen sehen
dass er das den bürgern auch etwas
zurückgeben der stadt schwimmt ihn
steuern die er das noch nie getan hat
wir haben haushaltsüberschüsse sowohl im
bund als auch gesamtstaatlicher es gibt
keine notwendigkeit für steuererhöhungen
weder auf bundesebene noch auf länder
ebene muss man von reuters zwei fragen
ein paar ski sie haben eben
unterstrichen dass sie eine konstruktive
opposition anstreben heißt das tier den
schulterschluss suchen mit der cdu würde
es deutet sich ein rot rot grüne senat
an und eine frage an die beiden
parteivorsitzenden am kommenden
wochenende gefäße einen konvent in
kassel nach einer
medienberichterstattung plant der
hessische landesverband einen antrag
nach dem nach möglichen islamistischen
anschlägen mit einer gezielt gegen
merkel gerichteten kampagne reagiert
werden soll
können sie etwas dazu sagen also sie
haben mich ja zuerst angesprochen ich
denke ich denke das habe ich klar
gemacht die afg wird keine fundamental
opposition sein sie wird sich auch
vernünftigen und guten vorschlägen die
die stadt nach vorne bringen und das
wohl der bürger im auge hat nicht
verschließen wir werden sehen wie sich
die arbeit mit den anderen parteien
gestaltet ich gehe davon aus
das eigentlich alle parteien das wohl
der stadt im auge haben müssten und
demzufolge eigentlich sich an den
sachthemen und an den ergebnissen
orientieren und nicht an dogmatischen ja
ich sag mal einschätzungen anderer
parteien
herr busemann der konvent der
parteikonvent eft ist eine nicht
öffentliche veranstaltung und deswegen
gibt es zu dem thema nicht zu sagen aber
ich meine das ist ja schon erheblich
wenn geschrieben wird dass es in der
überlegung gibt auf anschläge mit einer
gezielten kampagne zu agieren wollen sie
nichts dazuzahlen
herr busemann der konvent ist eine
nichtöffentliche parteiveranstaltung
über die tagesordnung was dort
verhandelt wird entscheidet der konvent
am tag der veranstaltung deswegen gibt
es dazu bisher nicht zu sagen
und wenn wir das gefühl haben dass es
was zu verlautbaren gibt dann hören sie
von uns habe ich das richtige micro ich
kann es nicht
also wie gesagt nur zwei entschuldung
morgens vom focus eine frage an alle
drei afd repräsentanten wie sie wissen
herrscht zumindest den medien vielleicht
aber auch bei ihren wählern rätselraten
darüber woher die mittel kommen mit
denen eine kampagne finanziert wurde die
ihren wahlkampf unterstützt hat dies war
jetzt bei den abgeordnetenhauswahlen der
fall wie zuvor auch bei den
landtagswahlen
sie haben bisher immer geltend gemacht
dass sie niemanden vermuten können
hinter dieser kampagne dass sie die an
organisatoren nicht kennen ich würde
einfach nur schlicht und einfach von
allen dreien von ihnen gerne wissen ob
sie bei dieser darstellung bleiben
herr moritz wenn sie erlauben weil wir
alle drei die gleiche antwort geben
übernehme ich das dazu können wir nichts
sagen weil wir es nicht wissen und
spekulieren werden wir nicht